in diesen tagen liebe zuschauer feiern
wir einen runden geburtstag
und wenn ich feiern sage habe ich direkt
gelogen die riester rente ist 20
geworden ja benannt nach dem
gleichnamigen walter hier gratulanten
gab es keine dafür diese demo vor dem
kanzleramt unter anderem die
verbraucherzentrale forderte die
beerdigung der riester-rente gute idee
tatsächlich hat die groko sie gerade
selber beerdigt der garantiezins für
riester produkte wurde nämlich von 0,9
auf 0,25 prozent gesenkt der de facto
todesstoß 16 millionen deutsche riestern
elf millionen zahlen noch ein obwohl
ihre versicherung ihnen viel zu hohe
gebühren abziehen plus horrende
verwaltungskosten diese menschen lässt
die politik im stich
nachdem man sie ins ries an rein
gelabert hat mit doofen spots wie dem
hier und jetzt kann jeder riester
meister werden renten tipps von einem
fußball millionär
die nullerjahre eine verrückte zeit die
idee an sich war ja gar nicht völlig
verkehrt wegen des sinkenden
rentenniveaus ergänzend privat vorsorgen
man hätte das ganze hat nicht den
versicherern zum fraß vorwerfen dürfen
das war der fehler die riester rente ist
ein total komplizierter unrentabler
quatsch durchschnittlich jeder vierte
euro denn ich da investiere landet gar
nicht in meiner altersvorsorge also es
ist bei riester-verträgen absolut üblich
dass ein hoher anteil der erträge sogar
der riesterförderung als steuergeldern
gezahlten subventionen für die kosten
drauf geht
absolute frechheit seit zig jahren allen
bekannt passiert ist nichts
obwohl im koalitionsvertrag steht man
wolle sich kümmern allerdings im ich
zitiere dialog mit der
versicherungswirtschaft natürlich vor
dem sumpf austrocknen immer die frösche
fragen hat sich bewährt besserverdiener
profitieren da noch einigermaßen aber
ein kinderloser single zum beispiel
zahlt 18001 um später 50 euro
pro monat zu kriegen großartig man muss
knapp 100 jahre alt werden um wenigstens
die kohle raus zu holen die man
eingezahlt hat aktuelle knaller idee der
versicherer sie sagen
wie wäre es denn wenn wir den kunden
ihre eingezahlten beträge nicht mehr
komplett garantieren sondern nur noch zu
80 prozent
aber wenn die versicherer jetzt keine
garantie zahlen müssen erhöhen die ihre
kosten also 1 1 garantie freies produkt
meinem versicherer ist unmöglich das ist
ja wie wir nicht mein blut spende für
eine blutbank wo die vampire die
buchhaltung machen da also mit
versicherungs heinis vergleichen als
vampir wäre tödlich beleidigt übrigens
hat die cdu csu fraktion die freche 80%
idee der versicherer fast eins zu eins
in ihr konzept übernommen
riester ist aber nicht mehr reformierbar
altes indianisches sprichwort wenn das
pferd tot ist steig ab stattdessen
brauchen wir endlich ein kostengünstiges
transparentes produkt besten staatsfonds
der für sich keine gewinne machen will
sondern rendite für anleger
erwirtschaftet schweden macht damit seit
jahren super erfahrung bei extrem
niedrigen verwaltungskosten warum haben
wir so etwas nicht macht mich tierisch
sauer
liebe mitbürger sie sind sauer auf uns
wegen riester verständlich aber bitte
bedenken sie auch viele politiker sind
riester opfer sie arbeiten hier im
bundestag immer weiter weil sie sich den
ruhestand einfach nicht leisten können
dieser rentner zum beispiel muss in
seinem alter noch minister werden weil
das sozialamt sonst sein flugzeug
beschlagnahmt er hier ist sogar schon
seit zehn jahren arbeitsunfähig hat aber
auch geriet dort wo dieser verwahrloste
gazprom-vertreter muss seine rente sogar
mit doofen influencer videos aufpeppen
soll nur diese frau geht schon mit 67 in
rente
denn sie hat statt den riester im
bitcoin investiert glückwunsch ok
bitcoin das schreibe ich mir mal auf
klingt interessant
ja manche experten sagen einfach selber
geld fürs alter zurücklegen wer sogar
klüger als riestern
andererseits wenn man darüber nachdenkt
sparen macht ja auch gar keinen spaß
mehr
und zwar nicht nur wegen der drohenden
inflation sondern vor allem ihr wegen
der negativzinsen ist doch so oder
also das heißt meistens für war entgelt
haben sich die banken auch immer klar
dazu bekannt dass es eben kein
negativzins ist sondern ein entgelt das
heißt dann ebenso schön verwöhnt geld
viel besser viel besser
es heißt auch nicht mehr mafia
schutzgeld sondern italienische kultur
zu lage immer mehr deutsche
kreditinstitute machen damit bei den
entgelten natürlich auch muss man sagen
ein stück weit aus notwehr weil sie
selber strafzinsen an die ezb zahlen
das heißt die banken verlieren geld wenn
ich ihm geld gebe hier so geht heute
bankraub
den nimmst du jetzt und taxi auf dem
tagesgeldkonto war meine kohle für mich
aber ohne verein geld ganz ruhig leute
das hier ist eine verdammt war zuerst
übrigens in der korona krise mussten
viele selbstständige ihre altersvorsorge
anknabbern
weil es nicht anders ging doppelt
tragisch in einer welt in der man gar
nicht mehr weiß wie man jenseits der
gesetzlichen rente für sein alter
vorsorgen sollen auf dem konto wird es
weniger priester ist tot die
lebensversicherung zuckt auch nur noch
was bleibt da ich sage es ihnen ja wer
als kleiner selbstständiger im alter
sorgenfrei leben will muss unbedingt
erben herzlich willkommen zu die
deutsche leberhilfe mit birte schneider
liebe zuschauer das geld liegt gar nicht
auf der straße oder auf der bank es
liegt hier eine rekord erbschafts welle
rollt gerade übers land man schätzt bis
zu 400 milliarden euro vermögen werden
in deutschland pro jahr vererbt oder
verschenkt sind er ist mir total
bescheuert wenn man nicht völlig
richtige oliver nun bitte ganz wichtig
unbedingt von reichen eltern erben jahr
ein drittel der gesamten erbmasse gibt
bei uns dann 1,5 prozent der bevölkerung
die hälfte der deutschen erb schulden
oder schlimmer noch gar nicht viel dorf
kann man nichts erben aber wird moment
mal was ist denn mit der erbschaftsteuer
wenn man die erbschaftsteuer ja nicht
umgehen aber vielleicht sparen möchte
dann sollte man einfach frühzeitig damit
anfangen den kindern etwas zu schenken
die haben ja pro kind 400.000 euro frei
und dann können sie alle zehn jahre den
etwas schenken bis zu 400.000 euro ja
papa guckst du gerade
hast du gehört was der mann da eben
gesagt hat du könntest mir 400 top ich
habe doch erklärt wie online-banking
gehege herreweghe das letzte hemd hat
keine taschen genau papa und der sack
hat kein regal aufgelegt unser staat ist
so pietätvoll ich kann ja ein vermögen
von 1,7 millionen an meinen mann und
meine drei kinder vererben ohne einen
cent steuern zu zahlen firmenvermögen
bleiben sogar bis zu 26 millionen
komplett steuerfrei wenn man es richtig
macht deswegen wird die erbschaftsteuer
auch die dummen steuer genannt er eben
zu dumm es sich beraten zu lassen
idioten steuer l übrigens nur die dummen
von der linkspartei fordern höhere
erbschaftssteuern nicht mehr die grünen
aber gut wenn der linkspartei ist rp
höchstens eine gammelige datsche in
bitterfeld apropos deutsche immobilien
auch eine super altersvorsorge jetzt die
schlechte nachricht selbst mit dem
niedrigzinsen können sich die wenigsten
normalverdiener heute noch ein haus
leisten
in vielen gegenden nicht mal
doppelverdiener mit 100000 auf der kante
heißt das etwa auch hier lautet die
lösung genau oliver berben 36 prozent
der immobilienkäufer sagen in umfragen
sie sind nur deshalb eigentümer weil sie
geerbt haben und weil deren geerbtes
geld den markt flutet steigen die
immobilienpreise immer weiter und nicht
aber gucken wie höhere mieten ist ja
auch schön oder
man spürte es spricht ja wirklich alles
fürs erben
ich will unbedingt auch erben muss ich
doch lieber jetzt wird es wirklich bis
hin zu nisch nun bitte nie vergessen
hinter jedem r besteht ja auch irgendwo
ein todesfall
deshalb ist es ja so wichtig mit seinen
eltern solange es irgend geht quality
time zu verbringen hallo mama wir haben
heute unseren mutter tochter tadel
wir gehen jetzt früh kleinen und
basejumper das brauchst du brauchst du
doch nicht doch ried kleinen brauchst du
doch kein mittel
mal war dass er voll uncool wirte
schneider
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und liegt -
wollt dann abonniert jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]